Me, as an architect and the professors like Mauricio Brocato as engineers,
we realized that Mathematica was a highly privileged sharing platform that can allow different people,
with different backgrounds, and different specific interests in their research,
but that share a common vision, to come together.
I am currently working as an associate professor at the National School of Architecture at Paris-Malaquais.
I had my first contact with Mathematica in 2003
during a scenography project that had been commissioned by the Pompidou center,
where we had to solve architectural formalism problems from a mathematical angle.
But with applications that vary based on the evolution of my work.
It started over right away when I was working on my thesis in architecture,
which led to the French graduate degree in architecture.
In the thesis, I worked on the problem of surfaces, on the problematic surfaces in contemporary architecture,
and that work was entirely written in a unique Mathematica notebook.
I would say that was the continuation of the first experience.
And I have also tried to introduce Mathematica increasingly in my teaching
at the School of Architecture at Paris-Malaquais.
We realized that Mathematica was a very privileged platform
because we were able handle extremely variable data.
In that school I try, since the curriculum is related to urbanism,
I try also to encourage students to work on Mathematica to do image analysis.
For various reasons, the classic softwares of architecture
have a whole bunch of concepts of architecture that are built-in within the software.
Simple things such as columns, beams, doors, windows, insulation, thickness of the wall,
and a lot of things like that that are very architecture-oriented and are very convenient.
And in the architectural education context, I see these things as too practical.
They do not leave enough room for architectural experimentation,
both more formal, more mathematized in some cases but also more conceptual.
With Mathematica you can explain to students how to draw a circle,
which is the same as what s/he learned in high school with a Cartesian equation.
We can do it with a parametric equation, but we can also do it in assembling four pieces of Bézier curves to draw the same geometric figure.
We have access to a rich geometry, and I would say a variety of mathematical tools
that are not accessible in regular modeling geometric software.
And the third big advantage for me is the format of Mathematica
the notebook, the interactivity that allows you to do everything in it.
You can write, you can import images, I won't say you can send sms, but almost.
You can... query databases on the internet.
Especially now with the coupling between the notebook and Wolfram|Alpha,
all those things seem absolutely essential to me.
And open teaching, and open, in a case, give students an opening to a world of data,
to a world of knowledge that is completely different from what they were used to before.
That's also what we are trying to teach our students. To remain relatively open.
Mathematica seems to be quite suitable, even a very suitable platform to explore,
to have a very exploratory approach.